we need to talk about some of the
celebrities that traded in Fame for
ordinary jobs starting off with this
absolute Queen who you probably know as
Teddy Duncan from Good Luck Charlie
while miss Bridget Mendler has been
quite busy since the Disney Channel Bays
you might have heard at some point that
she was getting her PhD from MIT but I'm
looking at her LinkedIn right now and
not only that but she's also getting her
Lottery from Harvard at the same time
and she's a CEO and co-founder of a
company this one I love and I just find
so fitting so read Alexander AKA Neville
Pepperman from iCarly is now an
entertainment correspondent and here he
is talking to CNN about the writer
strike okay so Kevin Jonas isn't really
out of the spotlight but he does have a
day job he's been managing his own
construction firm since 2014. and last
but not least Jennifer Stone AKA Harper
from Wizards of Waverly Place is now an
ER nurse